I know all y'all can't handle this sh** I know y'all gonna flag this fu**ing video like you always do
I know y'all cant handle this shit
I know y'all cant handle this shit. I know y'all are gonna fucking flag this video like you always do.
I know y'all are gonna fucking flag this video
Like you always do
and I have to call google and be like *telephone ringing*  "hey they flagged another one yeah my fan base is basically a bunch of pussys." Oh this video has blood in it!
and I have to call google and be like *telephone ringing*  "hey they flagged another one yeah my fan base is basically a bunch of p*ssies." Ooh this video had blood in it!
*telephone ringing*
"hey they flagged another one yeah my fan base is basically a bunch of pussys."
Oh this video has blood in it!
Oh this video had nipples in it! Oh this video was a little bit too sexual! Oh he may be swirl. Excuse me why don't you just go to the fucking Australia
Ooh this video had nipples in it! Oh this video was a little bit too sexual! Oh he made me swirl. Excuse me why don't you just go... to the f*cking... Australia
Oh this video had nipples in it!
Oh this video was a little bit to sexual!
Oh he may be swirl
Excuse me
Why don't you just go to the fucking Australia
Like the good old days alright?
What do you oh I bet you are gonna flag this video already
Because your triggered by my glasses
Ya'll a bunch of wimps
Don't flag fucking videos alright
Stop flaging the video I am sick and tired of this fucking shit
can ya'll stop flagging my f***ing videos? Stop flagging the videos. God d*mn it I don't make any money if you flag the videos.
can ya'll stop flagging my fucking videos? Stop flagging the videos. Goddammit I don't make any money if you flag the video.
Can ya'll stop flagging my fucking videos?
¡Stop flagging the videos!
¡GOD DAMN!
I don't make any money if you flag the video
What do you think? I do this for free? Do you think I am some kind of F***ing charity? Do you think I do this for fun? Do you think I do YouTube for fun?
What do you think I do this for free?
What do you think I do this for free? You think I am some kind of fucking charity? You think I do this for fun? You think I do YouTube for fun?
You think I am some kind of charity?
You think I do this for fun?
You think I do YouTube for fun?
I only in this for the money. F*ck you, for even thinking that! Alright now I gotta make this video and it'd be great if you don't f*cking flag it!
I only do this for the money
Fuck you for even thinking that!
¡Alright!
Now I gotta make this video and it'd be great if you don't fucking flag it!
Alright? Don't flag the video!
So if you're not up for the challenge
¡BITCH!
Then click the fuck away
And don't flag the vide-a!
Man I should be a rapper that was pretty good
I'm a bitch Imma click dislike
report as I swipe cause I hate my life
I'ma sit on YouTube nothin better to do
Flag all your videos cause I'm better than you
I'm a virgin cheetos on my fingers while I'm lurkin'
locked in my basement, kitchen to surface
never show my face keyboard is my fortress keep off the internet or you're gonna get reported
You p*ssies ain't sh*t with your sensitive b*tches. If this is offensive you don't have to listen.
Turn off the computer; do somthin' productive
you cancerous people accomplishin' nothin'
you hidin' behind the securities
weak human beings that breath immaturity
F*ck your opinion cause that sh*t don't mean nothin' to me
just pick the dislike and move on with your life